it's time for roses and rose a merry
Christmas everyone
Happy Hanukkah happy almost new year I
know what I want for the new year and
what I wanted for Christmas there
haven't gotten it yet but didn't want a
lot for Christmas there is just one
thing I needed I just want him for all
of our Rohan more than perhaps he even
know whose ABC made my wish come true a
brand new season with re for me and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys happy holidays I hope everyone
who celebrates Christmas had a wonderful
Christmas and for the new year we are
gonna get a new season of The Bachelor
but before then we got to finish off the
2012 apocalypse season finale that was
Emily Maynard's Bachelorette season 8
finale as we have been doing we've been
watching Emily I mean our season to
catch up so that we get to know our
before his season premieres January 1st
on ABC so let's do it
okay I am Bambi's it confounded
Confederate that's not even a word and
that's how confusing this season finale
was to me and to Ari and I do not blame
and I took something notes about how
confused I am here we go so season
finale we're gonna meet Emily's family
of course and you know what a Jeff met
at first but we're gonna skip over it
because why why bother why watch it we
know what happened they're not even
together anymore and she didn't pick Ari
so by E back to re meeting Emily's
family so re the editing made him seem
like a little awkward he's like I don't
know what Dave look I'm nervous my talk
I'm nervous or talk about fishing and
how it's hard to fish in the dark I
heard when it's overcast it's good to
fish I heard that's when they bite
whatever it was cute and then Ari's like
I got you a box am I gonna hope there's
something in the box it's like oh these
are the roses that was cute too and
Emily's family loved it and that was the
turning point
so Emily's family loves re and re loves
Emily Arie calls Emily she's loved my
life what foreshadowing and Emily's like
hoping her family will help her make
this decision between Arie and Jef
because she can't make it she can't
decide between the two at this point I
mean certainly in no position to decide
forward I see what he's saying cheers to
that guy
so Emily's gonna make the decision but
we're not really gonna understand it who
do we think is best for Emily how about
Arie more people seem to be cheering for
Jess and Ferrari I don't understand this
you guys when Ashley I can Eddie was
here she told me she loved Jeff that she
used to chant J e ass and I don't get it
so Emily goes on a date with Jeff which
were out they're not gonna watch and
Jeff needs her daughter Ricky and we're
not gonna watch that cut to the surprise
of this finale at the time so then we
get to this moment which had to be such
a shocker watching this finale live
instead of Emily's final date with Arie
forget Chris Harrison and Emily tells
him that she just wants to say goodbye
to our Arie it makes me cry just
thinking about is that why you're
confused today it's not even confused
which just family you've got respect her
I mean she didn't make him go through
the final date but I'm still I'm so
confused like Emily says nothing has
happened is to make Ari think that he's
going to be dumped by her which is so
painful to hear because I agree ari are
you stalking by we can't wait to propose
to her like this is gonna be dark and
then we cut to the moment where Emily's
gonna dump him and they even have Ari up
meet this woman in the woods and she's
gonna have him make a love potion for
Emily out of her herb garden oh that
potion is not gonna work like yes to
wait 15 minutes to suppose and see an
hour yeah and he makes that potion
Emily's there and he's like I gotta rub
it on you oh my god he's touching and
it's like one that potions really not
gonna work then he's like what's cool
necklace little Phoenix oh look at your
necklace you know he's so thoughtful and
he knows something he's like look at
your necklace this is that a Phoenix and
it's like this relationship is not gonna
rise from the ashes
yeah of course sir right here yeah even
though I know what's gonna happen
Oh sad just sad yeah
so Emily tells him the big the biggest
thing she can say to him is that she
just doesn't know anymore and I was like
what what what do you mean Sam I mean
she's not even saying I'm done she's
like I don't know anymore was at first I
be like are you dumping me are you not
are we just talking this out
no she's dumping him she's dumping him
but as Emily will admit later she's not
very good at it Emily even tells him she
always thought it would be him that she
was thinking about their future together
and picturing it what so what happened
what why and all that she could have
kind of said all she could say this
whole episode was that she just loves
Jeff a little more this is also
interesting you guys because I
interviewed Ari which is up at EC
online.com you can check it out and he
told me that he falls for two women and
that after being The Bachelor he now
understands Emily better and I now
understand what he meant by that because
Emily was basically a lot with two guys
I think so it was like really hard
ari says he's shocked and so are we and
then at the end even after this super
surprising dumping situation Arie is
such a class act he's like give me a hug
and good luck with everything and he
doesn't freak out or he's yell at her
and Ally like I love Emily she's kind of
a weird Criers and she I feel like the
whole season I hear her crying I don't
see it I don't see the tears but Ari
doesn't even cry he's just so I feel
like he's numb I feel like watching this
like he was in shock and
I am having this reaction years later
when I know the outcome good god this
show this so re even says that he still
believes Emily is the love his I still
believe that she is in love with my life
like that's what is so
[Music]
painful you know Wow cinematic truly
he's a good on screen kiss her and he
delivers the drama he's a top so then
we're gonna go to the live after the
final rose and hopefully gets more
answers and I have learned I need to be
more direct for sure and I need to learn
how to say that you know say things even
if it'll hurt hurt in the moment I know
it'll give you closure in the end Emily
admits that she did not give very much
closure late or not and that she did not
communicate the break-up very well and
and Ari says watching it really helped
him which I appreciate him saying cuz it
didn't really help me that much in the
end I don't understand why shouldn't
Bakari but okay in the end I just had
more confidence and what Jeff and I had
Emily just said she had more confidence
in her long-term future with Jeff well
that did not happen one thing that I
really liked is that watching after the
final rose Arie kept saying he just fell
like he was open the whole time so open
him and Emily agreed she's like you were
just so open and that's what Ari has
said to me in his recent interviews that
he was very open so open and so I think
he stuck to that and it makes me believe
he's genuine that that really is how he
is gonna use Bachelor and I hope that
based on the absolutely confusing
messaging that Emily sent him and the
branding of their breakup but Ari will
be more clear when he is dumping women I
you know he said he wanted to be
decisive and he would not be indecisive
as Bachelor and he did fall in love with
two women but I just hope that he he he
communicates that's what I hope this
story didn't end when she broke up with
you in Curacao then we find out that our
Arie couldn't deal with the break-up and
he flew to Charlotte
no cameras the producers didn't know he
wanted to have an off-camera
conversation with Emily and he flew to
Charlotte himself Wow
and then when he got there he was like
this is my best idea
so he called Emily and he left her his
journal at her house which he no like I
mean ultimately he could've just FedEx
it at that point
and emily has the journal dare in person
and we hear the packaging of it
crinkling and we know that she didn't
open it she says she never read it she
didn't want to read it and Wow you can't
write this stuff I mean this is like the
reverse of the notebook you know like
we're not gonna find out what's in there
re still says he wishes Emily would have
just told him look I'm happy with Jeff
and she's like I didn't want to pour
salt in a wound and it's like that's
what this show is about it's about salt
and wounds and wounds and Ahri's wounds
are still there five years later and by
that I mean you guys that he told me he
still he told me that he has not had the
same feelings since his feelings for
Emily in the past five years so while I
think he's moved on I see the pain of
this this was a lot it was a lot let's
just finish drinking this glass because
how much it was there was something
floating in the bottom of this glass but
they just managed to avoid at the end
there
that's called professionalism so we have
finished watching Emily Maynard season 8
of The Bachelorette to get to know Ari
because he hasn't on TV since 2012 and
you know what Ari told me he thinks
that's a good thing because these women
hopefully he has confessed ins didn't
have that last season to judge modeling
he just sketching of him for him so we
will see if that happened here's what we
know he fell in love with two women he
did not want to be an indecisive
bachelor and his season premieres
January 1st you guys I will be watching
it I cannot wait to watch it with all of
you thank you so much for reliving
Emily's season of The Bachelorette with
me and we'll be course doing roses and
Rosie for The Bachelor
and if you want to know more about re
head to an 18 online.com there's nothing
left and check out our things to know
about his season and check out our
interviews with him and I just hope
everyone has just the loveliest holiday
full of love because after watching
these two episodes I feel empty
because the love was not there well
we're gonna find it again love you guys
lot lot lot make sure to subscribe to ET
on YouTube and like us on Facebook and
you can check in with me on social media
anytime to talk a bachelor nation stuff
[Music]